pas
à bonjour vous êtes là je suis très
content de vous voir mais aujourd'hui je
n'aurai pas beaucoup de temps à vous
consacrer j'ai décidé de rester là et de
faire toutes les choses qui me plaisent
et que je n'ai pas le temps de faire
habituellement oui j'ai même j'ai même
tous marqué sur un emploi du temps - smi
cet emploi du temps il est là dans la
dans la malle de léonard ou encore
heureux que ce vorace ne l'est pas
grignoter bien alors première chose à
faire un rêver à la beauté des choses
qui m'entourent bon et bien prenons au
hasard la première chose
dont le joli petit nuage de poussière en
que c'est joli dans un rayon de soleil
un petit nuage de poussière
s'allumer alors que penses tu de mon
entrée spectaculairement acrobatique bon
alors vous savez moi pour me pour me
surprendre il faudrait faire au moins un
triple saut périlleux à bon ben je suis
navré et casimir oui bien écouter s'il
vous plaît poussez vous promettre 90 du
rayon de soleil que vous boucher
nets 98 très flatté casimir je me fais
seulement qu'un mètre 80 ah bon quand je
pensais que vous étiez plus grands
voiliers vous m' attends tu dis toujours
plus on est grand plus on est bête c'est
pour ça que je vous croyais beaucoup
plus grand toujours aussi aimable
enfin passons tu ne t'ennuies pas tout
seul casey mise non non pas du tout et
j'ai l'intention d'en rester ici sol
toute la journée bon avait dans ce cas
je repars pas voulu rentrer c'est ça ou
en place
il ne changera jamais bon
emploi du temps deuxièmement
deuxièmement en lire mon nouveau livre
de bande dessinée ça c'est formidable
j'adore les bandes dessinées bien sûr
tous les histoires de de fait et de cow
boy
voyons voyons
voilà c'est ici
j'espère que le joli cow boy va épouser
la jolie fait
nos vies je rentre alors qu'elle y lire
bonjour oui on ne t'a jamais appris
qu'il fallait frapper mais j'ai frappé
deux fois pas bon bon
excuse moi je lis mais j'étais tellement
occupée à lire mes bandes dessinées que
je ne t'ai pas entendu on raconte moi
une histoire alors que julie pas un
autre jour aujourd'hui je n'ai vraiment
pas le temps
pourquoi es tu venu ici mais parce que
je m'inquiétais de ne pas devoir dans le
jardin ah bon mais écoute j'ai décidé de
passer ma journée tranquillement sol ici
pour faire les choses que je n'ai jamais
le temps de faire bon bah tant pis
mauvaise et s'adresse à bientôt à
bientôt à bientôt
bien sûr j'en suis quasiment la seule
oui hélas bien concède
trop tard les très bons joueurs
quasiment alors troisièmement cher un
petit goûter pour prendre des forces
bonjour casimir
bon enfin méprend sanctuaire en pressant
frappé
oui c'est vrai je suis rentré sans
frapper excuse moi j'écrivais je vais
frapper d'accord
et voilà tu content non je ne suis pas
content quand il est pas content j'ai
compris j'y retourne way
qui est là c'est françois je peux
rentrer non il ne peut pas entrer et
bien casimir d'habitude dieu plus
accueillant peut-être mais aujourd'hui
je ne reçois personnes j'ai décidé de
rester tranquillement et seul casimir je
suis venu parce que j'étais inquiet mon
dieu je t'ai pas vu au jardin je faisais
du souci aux et bien la prochaine fois
je t'enverrai ambre histoire là bon et
bien casimir puisque c'est comme ça je
crois que la seule chose qui nous reste
à faire c'est parti comme ça alors je
pars c'est ça on se marre tu ne me
retient pas pourquoi on voir je pars
voyons la suite à quatrièmement lire
quelques jolis prime oui mon livre de
poèmes le voilà
je vais commencer par un très joli poème
de francis jammes ce cela s'appelle jan
j'aime l'anoci doux marchant le long d
où il a peur des abeilles et bouge c'est
zoraya il va après des fossés d'un petit
parc assez et réfléchit toujours à ses
yeux sont deux jours il reste à les
tables fatigue et misérable
casimir excuse moi je peux peut-être te
donner un petit coup de main je te
remercie prend forme et c'est tout à
fait inutile coucou c'est encore moi
encore je m'en suis pas d'aider à faire
une partie au travail non il n'en est
pas question
je ferai seul ce que j'ai décidé de
faire un bon je voulais de proposer des
teddy non non non et nous
c'est incroyable
je suis sûr qu'ils vont encore revenir
il faut que je trouve une solution
mais j'ai une idée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
c'est terminé
au moins maintenant plus personne ne
pourra me dérange et je vais pas être
tranquille chez moi papa
mais comment j'ai je rentre et je
me suis enfermé dehors ce pour ça alors
aux
antilles moi à
mes casimiro ne peut pas plus que tu as
tout fermé mais enfin j'ai mois au lieu
de rire
qu'est ce que je vais faire maintenant
et bien casimir tu n'as plus qu'à dormir
sous le paillasson
au monde au quasi mira
[Musique]